while not technically a shrimp the brine  shrimp is a crustacean found in salty  lakes and ponds and while they're  rebranding as sea monkeys is a more  recent Innovation artemia have been  around for over a hundred million years  artemia swim upside down and breathe  through their gills near the base of  their limbs and they spend their days  seeking out their favorite food algae  but artemia also make for great food  themselves which is why they are  cultivated to feed fish being farmed for  your own future meals or aquariums  that's actually how we got ours James  our master of microscopes ordered a  packet of about a million eggs on the  internet and then concocted his own  special Briny mixture like a mixologist  at a microscopic bar to give them the  right conditions to emerge in